Hello, I'm going to
start the presentation with the topic, Shouldn't we pursue functional programming in the front-
end?
There are many, and
recently I am interested in functional programs.
Yes, hello, I
am
Lee Chang-hee. Usually,
I am contributing to the whale ecosystem with JavaScript.
But
in this presentation, I will
explain a little bit of these theoretical things and explain
how to apply them in practice. You
may have heard that functional programming is a programming paradigm that processes data as pure functions and avoids side effects.
You may be wondering that all of these operations are likely to cause side effects. You are all
right, but
functional programming is not about
not using side effects at all.  It
means a programming paradigm that uses and pure functions together, manages them together, and combines the functions created here. First of all,
if so, I will explain how the team
introduced functional programming.  As I
progressed, I personally
studied related theories.
In the meantime, I wrote codes by introducing
simple functional methodologies to
actual projects.
As a result of the study,
Samsung programming
was conducted internally within the
team, and
during the internal study, there was a case where it was necessary to manage a complex state as shown in the picture.
This
exists, but
there is also a verification process that can be used in common in each of the different forms. This
part will be explained in more detail later by the creator.
First of all, among many functional programming
libraries, we
selected fpts and started developing it.
fpts  Why did you choose
fpts? fpts supports the
type abstraction supported by many functional programming languages.
Also, these
abstractions
all follow the fundamental theory of functional programming.
Also, there is an ecosystem of various libraries that can be used together with the library.
Before looking at examples, I
will introduce some necessary type abstraction and UT functions.
The option type abstraction
is a sum type composed of a run type and a sum type.
The code is broken, but I
don't know why.
Each container of
type a If a value exists, the
option type is a Thumb instance If
the value does not exist, the option type
is a Run instance
Option types typically
represent the effect of a computation that can fail Now
some examples using option types
Option types can be imported as in the first line. You
can create instances of each type using thumb type and non. The
find index function, which finds an index with a specific value in an array, if the value does not exist
returns -1 If it
succeeds in finding a value in the array, it
returns a thumb instance with the index value, if it doesn't find a value in the array,
it returns a non instance.  You
can see that an object with a zero value corresponding to the index of the array is returned.
Since there is no value of 4 inside the array, you
can see that the second instance with a nonn tag is returned.
Also, using the from love function  You
can also create an option type. If a
nullable value is passed to the from nullub function as an argument, a
null instance is returned. Conversely, if a
non-nullable value is
passed as an argument, a SUM instance with that value  In
addition, you
can create an option instance using a function called a prompt cater.
Prompt cat
takes a function that returns a boolean as an argument.  In
case the number function returns a churro, a
SUM instance is returned. In
case the number function returns a pulse, a
non instance is returned.  The
leader's instance is a left and a light
instance. The ether
type
can be used in place of an option to handle missing values, and the
nun instance in an option
is replaced by a left instance that can contain a value. In general,
left represents failure and  Light
expresses success
Let's look at a few examples of using the Inder type.
Ether is usually used when raising an exception. In
this example,
in this example, we'll use the tricatch function together.
String to JavaScript object
I implemented the parse function that converts to a leader to convert the
existing parse function using tri-catch. If the
function raises an exception, it
returns a left containing the error.
If the parse function executes normally, it
returns a light containing a JavaScript object.
Example  In the
case of an object that is converted successfully, an
object with a light property with a light tag value
is returned. In
case an exception occurs, an object with a left tag and a
left value is returned. Ether
types are also returned from nullable as in options.
and prompt can be used. The
difference is that Ether type receives a default value to be
used when left is returned.
If a null value is passed, a left instance
with the value passed by the function above is
returned.  You
can see that the light instance with the corresponding value is returned well.
It is the same.
When the left instance is returned, the
function that returns the value to be used is
additionally passed as the second argument. In
case the left instance is returned, the
prompt function  You can see that the
function passed as the second argument of is executed and
left int containing the value is returned.
If the function passed as the first argument returns true, an
index containing the value is returned.
Next, the task instance
Represents an asynchronous operation that does not fail. Asynchronous
operations that can fail
can use task Ether, which uses Ether as previously mentioned.  As long as it
waits for user input, it does not fail.
As shown in the picture, you
can see that the lead function is running normally. You
can use the tri-catch function in the same way.
When the promise is resolved, a
light instance with the resolved value is
returned.  Conversely, in
case of rejection,
the function passed as the second argument is executed, and the
return value of the second argument function
returns the
left instance with the return value. Since it is an asynchronous function, the
function is executed by using the keyword of washup together.
As explained earlier, you
can see that the instances appropriate for each situation are returned well.
Next,
I will introduce a UT function of fpts called pipe. There
is a curried function that adds two numbers as an example.
I made a function that adds 3.
How can I call a function if each function is executed sequentially as shown in the picture above?
In general, you
can compose a function by calling a function inside a function call like this  Yes,
but
what happens if the number of synthesized functions increases? You
can see that the code becomes very complicated.
What would happen if you create an individual function every time you make a
function call to make it easier to see?
Using the pipe function, you
can simply compose the function as shown in the example. At
a glance, it is
much easier to follow the flow of
function composition.  All you need to
do is read
Pipes, the utility function introduced,
is currently limited to JavaScript operators
How can you use the type abstractions described above?
To use type abstractions, you need to know
a few functions that can be used together.
It is a function. It
plays the same role as the map function in JavaScript arrays. A map function is also called a map
function or a map function. It
receives a function that accepts type abstractions and returns a value of type b as a value of type B.
As in the code in the material, in the case of a thumb type  In the map
function, the
function passed to the map function is executed. If you
follow the pipe, you can see that the string type
met the from nullable function and became an option, and the
type changes according to the signature of the function passed to the wrap function.  If is
passed, the
passed function of the map function is not executed.
Since the passed function of the prompt returned a pulse,
a nonce was passed and
therefore the result of that code is a non.
Next is the chain function. The
chain function computes the following  It is
used to decide whether or not to
continue the subsequent calculations using the result of the previous calculation. I
will explain the chain of Ether type as an example. The
multibyte function
multiplies by 10 if the input value is a number,
Returns an
instance of left instant containing a string if the input is not a number
increment takes a number and returns a
light instance containing the value added by 1
Combined these functions into a new
function  Since the passed value
is a string, the
multiple byten function
returns a left instance.
Therefore, the
increment function passed in the chain is
not executed, and the
left instance and
finally returned.
Conversely, if the passed value is the
number 11,
the multiple byten  The ten function
returns a light instance containing the number 100. The
light instance is
passed to the chain function, and the
increment function passed in the chain is called, and you
can see that the light instance added by 1 is returned.
Finally, to the mat and fold function
Sales fold has the same function, and in the
case of option type, sum and in the
case of insert type,
left and right
functions are passed and executed depending on the case.
If the value passed to the pipe is not 0  The prompter ship
returns a SUM instance.
If the SUM instance is passed to the match function, the function passed as the second argument is
executed.
If the first value passed in the pipe is 0, the
prompter ship does not  Returns an instance.
If you pass an instance to the match function, the function passed as the first argument
will be executed. So far, we've covered some type
optimizations, pipe functions, and
how to use the type abstraction to use the top and bottom of the type.
Now, I will introduce an
example of solving a real-life problem using theories
was now creating a recruitment site, and
as a result, we had to conditionally manage a
total of 8 items in the form for applying for employment.
And if the verification failed, there
was such a common problem that the user had to show an error message.
First of all, if there are
too many fields here, it's
high school, so now I
think there is only one mobile phone number field, and now I'll look at the code.
Then there will
be two states: a state that manages the mobile phone number value and a state that contains an error message to see if there is a problem with the mobile phone number value.
And now there
will be logic to actually verify that the mobile phone number is correct.
And now  Well,
whenever the user changes the input, the
state value will now be managed through the on-change event.  There
is a process.
Now the
data in the conference to be shown to the user is now spam containing the input entered by the user and the
error message.
Here, it is simply wrapped in a span.
To recap, we
'll need a total of four to implement one verifiable field: two states, one field validation function, and now an event handle function that detects an input value in that field.
But if this is
actually our  It is said that
manages 8 inputs. A
total of 16 states
will need to be managed within the conference. This comment
handler and
validation logic will have to be
written separately.  If
we
implement it as it is, the
code of the component will look a bit like this.
But we now
wanted to minimize this excessively stretched code in the component,
so we
agonized over how to solve this problem.  I
think people are thinking about how to solve
this problem now. Yes, in fact, there are
already
well-made libraries such as React WhoForm or Format that solve this problem.
So, in most cases, we
will use something like this.
Now, within the tip, there was some consensus that functional
programming
should be applied in earnest.
So, I decided to apply
the library called fpts, which I had used very simply in other projects before,
here as well.
Before solving the problem, we
What part are you going to rewrite using this fpts?
So, it
checks whether the entered value is correct and
shows an Ur message if the verification fails.
Buthere, only
three parts, the input value and the error message verification function, change in the implementation or object for each field outside.
Here, the rest of the parts are
common  These are the tasks that are done in all fields.
So, I thought that we could write the code comfortably if this input value or message validation
function injects three values ​​from the outside.  We
solved this problem by going through 4 steps to solve this problem.
Now, here, we will show you the code that we actually
applied to production, and
show you how it works and how to use it.
This validation function is now a
validator with function parameters,
so the functions that validate each field are
functions, and an
error message to be displayed to the user when validation fails, and the
return value of this function to this function is now
actually
validating the value.  The
currying function that receives the value to be done
consists of
this.
There is a curried function like this.
This function now first receives the value entered by the user and
is passed to the inner frompredicate function.
This prompt is now the first
argument, and now
two functions  I saw the function. The
first person
is now the logic that checks a certain value by passing the passed value
here.  By
passing the entered value to the using function, it is checked whether this value is
correct according to each rule or not.
If not, the
result value of the function passed as the second argument here will be received.
Here, we
will use the value to contain the left type of the result value of the function as an error message, so
here is a very simple error message like this  I
wrote it as a function that returns. If you
look at how this function actually works, here is where the
user
inputs a cell phone number that looks correct and a slightly incorrect phone number,
respectively.
I made it work in such a way that it shows the message.
And now I
went through the step of defining the validation rules that I said earlier.
This is what we showed you in the first simple
example component.
Just atomically split the verification ticks one by one.
When verifying, in fact, there are some stocks that are used only in one field, but in
most cases, the
minimum length is more than a few characters,
or it is required,
or the maximum number of characters should not be entered.  I
tried to increase the reusability by making it like this because there are rules to use. If you
check how to use it
now, the first to the third
now
consist of only numbers, and it
starts with 01 and does not exceed 11 characters.
All three now return true, but
in the rule that the minimum length at the end must be at least 10 characters, this
violates this, so a false occurs here.
Next, it's a part to create a validator to
use for each field using the guesses made earlier.
As a whole, this verification function was
implemented using a function called pipe, which was mentioned earlier. Here, too, the
first time the user entered, the
phone number entered by the user was
first received, and then it
was passed to the validator function.  I
made it to pass along the verification rules and error messages that I made in
Yes, here now, at first, this
value is required. This value is a
value that is required to be entered in this form, so whether one or more characters
have been entered.  , and if the
user has not entered anything, it
will return an error message saying that it is a required item to the left type.
If
any value is entered now, the
light type will be available.
Ether, so the
left or
right type, is passed as an argument to a function called
Chain of Ether, which follows immediately.
Here, the
chain function
is a function that receives the Ether type received as an argument. If the value received is
left or right, it does nothing.
The input left type is
sold again as it is. If the
right type came too much,
then the validating function
passed as the argument of the chain now
passes the value of the alt type to the function as an argument again.
If you
find anything, you will receive an error message saying that it is now a required item of the left type, and
the value that has now failed verification in the wrong second validate is now in the type that is not correct here. You will
have to receive an error message.  If
everything was done with the gun without any problems, the
phone number value entered by the user at the beginning is
put in the light type and returned again.  The
name of the review
is the name, but
as the name suggests, overall it's
just a user skater interface that's
verysimilar.
This hook
has another two states internally, each of which actually manages values, just
like we did in the live component code we created earlier.  There
are two states in which the form manages the error message.
And here, I made a function similar to the state that sets the change error,
that is, the
error message,
by wrapping it separately. The part that
returns the error message entered here is
now
state  I'll explain it
when I explain the object called Validor.
Yes, and Change Value.
Now, I made a
function similar to the state to be sent from the inside to the outside.
I checked once whether this was returned or whether the right type was returned, and then I used a function called Ether Match to
make different actions depending on the left and right types.
Now here, if the Ether
Match function is now a total of two functions  The
first is a function that
executes when the leader received as an argument is a lift. The second
argument is a function that executes when a light is used.
Here, when left,
I found a function provided by appts called Identity. In the case of identity  We
just have to look at the
value passed as the argument of the function entered literally
the same way.
We assumed here that the left
always receives an error message,
so it would be
nice if you could understand that we just return the incoming error message as it is.
And  If it is a light type, it
now
receives the entered value, now does a
state, and then
returns an empty string.
So
if there is actually an error message, the string for the error message will come too. If there is no problem then  Since
we made the
empty string finally return
when the empty string type came in just before, the
empty string will be passed.
With the finally passed string like this, we
now set an error.
And now we set the
skate validator
validator
separately  I made it, but now, when we
actually
set a value, it
doesn't change the state every time the value changes, but now,
like the same situation,
there are cases where we have to go through form validation again at the point we want to do it manually.  It
consists of a validation function that can be called manually and now a gatter that allows the user to easily get the value whether or not there is an error in this field.  If you
look at how we improved the existing code with these validation rules while validating a total of 4 things that have been created so far,
these parts that are now highlighted here are
coded in one line to live the field validation rules and custom hooks we have created.  We
can support it, and
now we
change the value, verify
something in the onchange event handle,
verify, and then set the rising message, and
these parts are all handled internally
in the custom hook we just created,
so
something more  Unless there is a special task, it
can be made simpler like this.
And even
in the part of verifying once more when buying Subway,
originally there was a part that manually called
each field by putting the value of each field in the verifier like this, but this
part is now also  Now that the interface is
unified with a function called state validation, you
can now manually verify many fields at once with only an array in the state validator.
Now, for State Valley, it is
not held inside the component by using an error gatter, but
now the user does not care and has
made this change so that it can be used more comfortably by
simply taking it.
To summarize, we will look at what a functional
program is roughly,
what kind of things exist in the fpts library we wrote,
and how we used this to
build up existing logic and
simplify implementation.  I
made some good and bad points now. First of all, it was good that
we were
able to define and solve the problem a little better with the time level.
How should side effects be handled now to be cleaner?
We
were able to feel a lot of the thoughts of functional programming like this while developing the front-end, and
when the team introduces new technologies or concepts, how
can we smoothly integrate them into the team?  They were children while
worrying about whether there would be such a part,
so this is
connected like a point that was a bit disappointing.
Those who have no experience or have had a bit of a hard time
writing and reading the code at first.
It's a bit longer than we thought.  I
felt that I would need more, and we approached it now with the mindset of writing
all the code if possible at first,
but in fact, there
were cases where it was cleaner and more readable to just write it in plain JavaScript.
Now, it would be nice to selectively apply
this to the part that says it would be a little
cleaner and more comfortable than all the national tax hearings,
and
there are not many up-to-date data and public opinion, and there are no
official documents unless they are
kind.  Now, even when applying this to the team, there
was a lot of difficulty in finding something.  It's been a while since I've been
Kate, so
this is just a little bit unkind official
document and
proceeding together or something like that, I
had a lot of trouble at first.